Joining us now from campaign
senior advisor
and daughter-in-law
to the president Lara Trump
Laura welcome back to Fox News
Sunday thank you Great to be
with you Chris let's start with
the president's health his
doctor put out a memo yesterday
that said this.
He is no longer considered
a transmission risk to others,
but it doesn't say that he
tested negative Laura is
your father-in-law Now free
of the coronavirus is it gone
well according to the White
House medical staff it sounds
like that's the answer obviously
working at the campaign we do
not conduct any testing on him
ourselves.
So if the White House doctor
says that he is free
of transmission.
I think that that sounds like
he's he's done with
the coronavirus and by all
accounts,
he should be able to go out
and get back on the road
campaigning he certainly should
be able to do a debate
on October 15 but we know
the debate commission decided
against that they wanted it
virtual but it sounds by all
accounts like he is free
of the coronavirus OK we'll get
to that debate in a moment as we
said just a moment ago
the president held an event
on the South Lawn of the White
House yesterday and while people
were not socially distanced many
but not all were wearing masks
having said that that's a lot
better than two weeks ago
at the event for Judge Amy Cody
Barrett where people were packed
in
almost no masks and Dr. Fauci
has said that that then was
a super spreader question why
did it take the president
getting COVID for the White
House to take the CDC safety
guidelines more seriously
although even yesterday they
were still violating some well
at that Amy Tony Barrett event.
Look I think most of those
people if not all of those
people were tested
for coronavirus before sitting
down for that event.
And you'd never hear Chris
on the other side of the coin,
the fact that we have had
in this country since really
the height of the comet days
these demonstrations across
America riots in the streets,
peaceful protests some of them
many of them not peaceful all
across America but you never
hear any concern after these
things about though those being
super spreader events I have yet
to hear one doctor say anything
about them I have yet to hear
one media outlet say anything
about those it doesn't seem like
coronavirus would have
a political agenda
but oftentimes it feels like it
does because those events are
never talked about as being
an issue.
So look the White House has
always followed guidelines
they've always either tested
people before they're around
the president or whenever there
is not testing available
for the number of people that
are there encourage people
to wear masks and honestly if we
all look at this from from
the same perspective it
doesn't seem right that
we're criticizing one event
and not another well I take
your point about the protests
but that doesn't make what
happened at the White House
which as I say Tony Fauci says
was a super Spider at least
eight people at that event later
came down with the virus,
including the president
and the first lady I got to ask
you because you were there about
another event, which was
the first debate 12 days ago
in Cleveland the Cleveland
clinic's rules were very clear
everyone in the audience had
to wear a mask but after
the first family came in with
mouse you all took them all off
did you think Laura that
the rules that applied
to everybody else in that hall
didn't apply to you well
of course,
we didn't think that and first
of all say that everyone
in there Chris was tested
and tested negative for four
COVID of it at least
in our family before we even got
on the plane to head out
to Cleveland and we walked
in with the masks on we sat down
all of the seats were socially
distance and I've heard you
actually say this many times I
want to be very clear never one
time did anyone from Cleveland
Clinic come up and ask any
member of our family to put
a mask on so that is totally
false I know that that notion
has been out there that is not
true we were respectful
to people around
us coming and we wanted to to do
that to walking with the mass
and we sat down we didn't move
from those seats until the very
end until it was all over and we
felt like we were being safe.
Those are the same guidelines
applied to restaurants those are
the same guidelines applied
to too many outlets across
America and the fact that we had
tested negative Chris, I mean
you know look we followed
the rules as we thought that
they were given to us well I
don't want to belabor this
I'm going to move
on but everybody in that hall
had tested negative.
I had had a test three days
before you couldn't get
in the hall without testing
negative and and the fact is
the rules were everybody except
for the president the vice
president and I were supposed
to wear masks and it was
the pool report.
I'm not making this up the pool
report says that a member
of the Playboy clinic
and in fact, there's video that
exists coming up to somebody
in the presidential party
and saying,
would you like masks and they
were waved away well they
didn't ask any member
of our family what I understood
afterwards is that Colby
Covington who was sitting behind
me had a magic mask on and they
didn't appreciate that
apparently so I think they were
coming up to offer him maybe
a different mask that's all I
can tell you about it but never
once Chris was anybody from
our family asked to put a mask
on I want to ask you about some
of the president's actions this
week on Tuesday he tweeted this
I'm going to put it up
on the screen I have instructed
my Representatives to stop
negotiating on COVID relief
until after the
election walking away from talks
with Nancy Pelosi by Friday,
the president was saying this I
would like to see a bigger
stimulus package frankly than
either the Democrats
or the Republicans are offering
I'm I'm going in the exact
opposite now OK how could
the president go in three days
from saying that the top offer
was $1.6 trillion two on Friday
three days later saying he
wanted to do more than Nancy
Pelosi is $2.4 trillion which
now Republicans are rejecting
this far too much Well I think
first and foremost,
let's point out the fact that I
think most people can agree
Nancy Pelosi was not serious
about this negotiation this was
a liberal wish list as have they
all been when it comes to these
these stimulus bills with Nancy
you know defunding the police
bailout money for states that
were in huge deficits well
before COVID hit hit any of them
trying to bail them out
for their bad decision making
from Democrat governors
and and look the president is
entitled to change his mind I
haven't specifically talked
to him about this but you know
maybe he got some different
information I can tell you Chris
the bottom line is that he wants
what is best for
the American people you saw
the way he pushed forward
the Paycheck Protection Program
in the middle of COVID to make
sure that small businesses can
stay afloat that people could
weather this storm.
This is no different he
understands that there are
people out there who desperately
need this money but it feels
like the Democrats and Nancy
Pelosi are yet again playing
politics and that is not what we
need right now I got one last
question we got one last minute
to talk about it when
the Commission on Presidential
Debates announced this week that
it was going to change
the debate that as you mentioned
his comment was supposed to come
up on Thursday the 15th from
in-person at town hall
to a virtual town hall
the president immediately pulled
out that debate has now been
canceled I understand why
the president would have
preferred an in-person debate
but that
wasn't what was on the table
didn't he make a mistake
regardless of what you think
of the commission
didn't the president make
a mistake because he's now lost
one of his last two chances
to confront Joe Biden on camera
well I don't think so look I
think a virtual debate is just
a complete disaster quite
frankly, we see even now when
we're talking there's a delay
in communication.
This is how it goes virtually
you cannot have a legitimate
debate with somebody virtually
and I know look who's to say
what happens on the other end
of things what happens
on the Trump side what happens
on the Biden side nobody knows
these two men should be on stage
there is no reason that they
shouldn't be 175 doctors told
the New York Post that they
think that the president without
a doubt should have been able
to do this it made no sense
and good for the president
for calling it out why did
the debate commission Chris
decide early on no,
we're not going to add a fourth
debate like the Trump campaign
was pushing for because they
didn't want to change the rules
they told us now they're willing
to change the rules without
reaching out to our campaign
made us what second decision
the day after the vice president
had a very strong debate against
Kamala Harris it seems a little
suspect to people.
And I think a virtual debate is
an absolute disaster good
for the president for saying no
they need to be in person Laura
thank you Thanks for your time
this week and always good
to talk with you and happy
birthday tomorrow thank you
and happy birthday to you
as well.